Counting is one of life’s most basic skills
and something most humans are quite adept
at.
Despite most of us being experts on the subject,
theoretically capable of counting infinitely
high with the ceiling bounded only by available
time and how good we are at staving off psychosis,
few can accurately guess how long it would
take to count to a million, let alone a billion.
This is largely owing to the fact that our
brains have an amazing amount of difficulty
conceptualizing such large numbers.
This all brings us to the question of the
hour- just how long would it take to count
to a million or a billion?
Let’s start with a million.
The most commonly put forward time it would
take to count from one to a million out loud
is about 23 days.
This time frame is cited in a number of textbooks
we consulted and seems to have originated,
as far as we can tell, in a children’s book
suitably called, How Much is a Million by
David Schwartz, which uses various examples
to put into perspective how amazingly big
numbers like a million really are.
Given the figure being cited in many a textbook
and first appearing in a book literally titled
How Much is a Million, you might assume it’s
reasonably close to correct.
This is not the case, however; this number
significantly underestimates the actual time
needed.
You see, Mr. Schwartz wasn’t trying to come
up with a real world figure here, just a simple
exercise to blow kid’s minds without bogging
them down in the details.
As such, there are a couple assumptions being
made in the “23 days” figure that turn
out to make it completely useless as a real
world estimate of how long it would take to
count to a million.
The first assumption is that the person counting
would be able to do so 24 hours a day non-stop.
The second assumption is not quite so absurd
on the surface: assuming that it would take
only about 2 seconds on average to say each
number.
However, while certainly some of the lowest
numbers can easily be said much faster than
that and with little time needed for thinking,
the majority of the numbers for an average
speed speaker would take slightly longer.
For example, just consider how long it would
take you to say out loud “one hundred ninety-five
thousand five hundred sixty-five”.
Granted, when speed speaking, one can easily
hit the 2 second mark, or even less.
But when actually counting aloud for many
hours on end, there is a certain level of
physical and mental fatigue that goes along
with it that makes it so speed speaking isn’t
really viable long-term.
This is a marathon, not a sprint.
So just how long would it actually take someone
to count to a million?
Thanks to the efforts of one Jeremy Harper,
we know the real world answer is somewhere
in the vicinity of 89 days.
How did Mr. Harper figure this out?
Well, he did it from June 18 to September
14, 2007 and live-streamed the entire thing
online for everyone to watch.
Harper, a software engineer whose boss gave
him time off to do this, neither left his
apartment nor shaved during the event; he
recited numbers aloud (read off a computer
monitor) for about an average of 16 hours
every 24 hour period for 89 straight days.
This is about 3.9 times longer than the oft’
quoted 23 day estimate.
To be clear, we’re not saying this all couldn’t
be realistically done faster.
Harper did take the occasional mini-break
to break out in dance and things of this nature-
he wasn’t trying to set a speed record to
count to a million.
However, given his overall pacing when counting
was reasonably quick, he dedicated the vast
majority of his waking hours to the task at
hand, and the large sample size of counting
time we’re dealing with here, this seems
a pretty good ballpark figure to go with on
the “How long does it take to count to a
million?” front.
As for why Harper did it, he was looking to
raise money for Push America (now The Ability
Experience), a charity that helps disabled
people.
Along with raising about $12,000 for the charity
directly (and getting them a lot of free publicity),
Harper’s achievement was recognised by no
less of an authority than the Guinness Book
of Records for being the highest number ever
counted to by a human.
As you might imagine, the reality of spending
nearly every waking moment for just shy of
three months doing nothing but counting aloud
was extremely mentally taxing according to
Harper.
As he noted, “The cameras that were on the
whole time, I think, are really what kept
me sane through the whole thing.
If I would have been locked in my apartment
and counted to a million and nobody was watching,
I would certainly have lost my mind.
I would be like, you know, just out of it.
”
Naturally, after hitting 1,000,000, he did
what anyone would do after such a momentous
achievement- the chicken dance.
As for the feeling of finishing counting higher
than any person before, according to Harper:
at that moment, I lost – I just kind of
lost all control, and then, you know, I said
the number.
And then, it was just like a big bubble – it’s
kind of – just popping on me.
At one time, I just said it and went with
it.
You know, there’s a weird emotion.
Now, within those 89 days, it took Harper
about 1,424 waking hours, or about 5.13 million
seconds to count to a million doing almost
nothing but counting.
This would mean the real world average time
to speak each number is roughly 5.13 seconds
or about 2.6 times slower than Mr. Schwartz’s
2 second assumption.
Granted, when we timed Harper saying some
of the largest numbers here and averaged it
out, the two second mark wasn’t that far
off, ending up around 2.6 seconds each.
But in between time was needed to, you know,
breathe, give the tongue, jaws, etc. a quick
rest, and take time to think about the next
number on the screen before saying it, to
avoid messing up.
So what about a billion?
As no one has ever counted that high (and
no individual human ever will unless we solve
that whole mortality thing), it’s difficult
to get quite as accurate of a general ballpark
figure.
Seemingly the best way to do this would be
to gather, say, 10,000 people and have them
all take 100,000 number long segments out
of the 1 billion number line and begin counting.
We’d then simply need to add up the total
time and get a good rough estimate.
But as we don’t know 10,000 people willing
to volunteer a couple weeks of their lives
to such a task (unfortunately), we’ll give
it our best college try at an estimate using
Harper’s numbers as a reference point.
On that note, as a sort of baseline, if we
assume that the average time to say each number
was the same as around what it is to count
to one million, and assume the same very reasonable
criteria as Mr. Harper used (counting roughly
16 hours per day with small breaks here and
there to eat, drink, etc.), that would be
a whopping 5,126,400,000 seconds or 1,424,000
hours of actual counting time.
After adding in the other eight hours of the
day, this comes out to 89,000 days or roughly
244 years.
(And if you’re curious about the whole “no
need to do anything else but count” scenario,
that would be roughly 59,333 days or about
163 years.)
But, of course, the time to say each number
would actually go up slightly as one ascended
the number ladder.
But how much?
Considerably based on a few practice runs
we attempted on some of the larger numbers.
Beyond it being much harder than you might
expect keeping the large number in your head
to increment appropriately (an issue that
could be avoided via reading the numbers off
a screen as Harper did), the actual average
time to say something like “three hundred
twenty two million four hundred fifty two
thousand seven hundred ninety nine” for
us was around 4 seconds at a normal speaking
pace.
Given Mr. Harper averaged an additional roughly
2.5 seconds in between each number, we’re
looking at a slightly more realistic number
(though still with a large error bar) of around
6.5 seconds average for those larger figures.
The lower digits, of course, would be closer
to Mr. Harper’s 5.13 total seconds, but,
as with counting to a million, the upper end
would come to dominate pretty quickly.
So just for an exceptionally rough ballpark
figure, we’ll go with a more realistic 6
seconds per number average, giving us around
1,666,667 hours or 104,167 days (counting
16 hours per day) or roughly 285 years, assuming
one had the benefit to get to read the numbers
off a screen.
(Without this, we’re quite certain given
our little practice runs with counting such
large figures, that it would take much, much
longer due to added interim seconds needed
for focusing/thinking in order to keep the
number in one’s head… and stave off a
mental breakdown as the years go on.)
So how long would it take to count to a billion?
We’ll go with somewhere between 244-285
years counting for about 16 hours per day.
If you happen to know 10,000 people who want
to dedicate a couple weeks to counting, maybe
we can come up with a more accurate figure.
Now that’s all counting to a billion with
normal speaking pace.
Just for fun, we were curious what the fastest
speaker in the world could do assuming the
unrealistic scenario of being able to motor-mouth
all day.
According to the Guinness Book of Records,
the fastest talkers in the world can speak
over 600 words per minute, such as Sean Shannon
and Steven Woodmore.
This is about four times faster than a normal
speaking pace, meaning Shannon or Woodmore
could count from 1 to a billion in about 71
years given the previous stipulations… you
know, if they had nothing better
to do.